A szinergia az a pillanat, amikor két
fél teljesen nyitottan egy harmadik
[zene] megoldást keres.
Sziasztok! Ebben az epizódban a
Szinergia alapelvéről fogunk beszélni,
vagyis a hatodik szokásról. Ez a szokás
arról szól, hogy a különbözőségeink nem
akadályok, hanem ajándékok. A szinergia
az nem kompromisszum, vagyis 1 + 1 az
nem másfél lesz, hanem 3, 5, 50 vagy
akár 100 is. Valahol minden egyes
szinergikus kapcsolatban otthon a
meghökkentő, a váratlan, a varázslatos.
Erről fogunk beszélgetni, hogy hogyan
tudunk egymással szinergikus
kapcsolatokat kialakítani. De mielőtt
belevágunk, hogyha értékesnek tartod ezt
a témát, kérlek, iratkozz fel a
csatornára, hogy ezek az alapelvek minél
több emberhez eljuthassanak.
Egy kicsit beszélgessünk a szinergiáról,
hogy mi is a szinergia lényege. A
természetben rengetegszer találunk olyan
példát, amikor több különböző dolog
egymásra építve, egymás erősségeit
kihasználva valami sokkal, de sokkal
erősebbet hoz létre, mint amit előtte
külön-külön el tudtak volna érni.
Például az erdőben a fák gyökerei,
hogyha összekapcsolódnak, akkor együtt
több vizet és tápanyagot tudnak
felvenni, mint külön külön amennyit fel
tudnának venni. Ugyanez érvényes amúgy
az ötvözetekre is. Külön-külön a
szakítósziládsága egy-egy fémnek
alacsonyabb, mintogyha ötvöznénk ezeket
a fémeket. És ugyanez érvényes az emberi
kapcsolatokra is, hogyha különböző
véleményeket, különböző nézőpontokat
ötvözünk egymással, sokkal teljesebb,
sokkal izgalmasabb és sokkal jobb
megoldásokat tudunk hozni, hogy egy
adott problémát közösen megoldjunk.
Nézzünk egy pár példát az emberi
kapcsolatokban rejlő szinergiáról,
ugyanis példák által fogjuk ezt
mélyebben megérteni, hogy hogyan is
működik maga a szinergia. Ilyen példa
például a híres DVD-nek a feltalálása,
vagyis az elterjedése. Ugyanis az addigi
hordozók, mint például a CD, már nem
volt alkalmas arra, hogy egy két órás
nagy felbontású mozifilmet lehessen
forgalmazni. Úgyhogy a nagy médiacégek,
mint például a Panasonic, vagy a
Toshiba, vagy a Sony összeültek és
elkezdtek gondolkozni azon, hogy hogyan
is nézzen ki a jövő média hordozója. És
mindegyik cégnek megvolt a maga a
kutatási területe. Van amelyik cég a
karcolásmentes felületeket, vagyis
hogyan olvassa ki az adatokat akkor,
amikor apró karcolások vannak a a CD-nek
a az alján. Másik a méretét növelte meg,
hogy 4 GB-os vagy akár 5 GB-os méretű
fájlokat is lehessen rajta tárolni. És
mindegyik cég a maga erősségét a közösbe
behozta. Így született meg valójában a
DVD, amit ma ismerünk, és az én
generációmnak egy hatalmas hozadéka
volt. Vagy vegyünk egy másik példát is.
A Melinda and Gates Foundation egyszer
azon gondolkozott, hogy hogyan lehetne a
maláriát megállítani. Ugyan ugyebár a
malária az rovarok által, pontosabban
sznyogok által volt terjesztve, és ez
egy adott probléma volt, hogy a
szúnyogokat hogyan lehetne eltávolítani
egy-egy indiai faluból. ugyanis az
addigi módszer szerint vegyszereket
szórtak a levegőbe, ami önmagában is
káros volt, nem csak a szúnyogokra,
hanem az emberekre is. Úgyhogy hasonlóan
különböző tudósok összeültek, hogy meg
megvitassák, milyen más módszereket
lehetne kidolgozni. Például egy
insektológus, egy rakétatudós és egy
szoftvertervező mérnök, és sokan más,
sok más területről még összegyűltek
emberek, egy jó ideig beszélgettek, és
igazából nem jutottak előre a
megoldásba. Addig ameddig az egyik ötlet
az volt, hogy hát miért nem lőjük le
lézerrel. Mindenki meglepődött, mit
jelent, hogy lézerrel lelőni. Hát
igazából meg tudjuk ezt csinálni.
Folytatta tovább, mert ugyanis be tudjuk
mérni pontosan a pozícióját, hogyha
tudjuk azt, hogy hogyan ismerjük fel a
szúnyogot. Erre mondta az insektológus,
hogy ez könnyű válasz, mert a
frekvenciáját pontosan be tudjuk mérni a
szúnyognak, a azt a frekvenciát, amivel
a szárnyai vernek. Hasonló módon a
rakétatudós is elmondta az ő véleményét,
hogy hogyan lehet nagyon hatékonyan
kiszámítani a pályáját ennek a
szúnyognak, és így egy meglepő és
váratlan fordulat következett be.
Ugyanis tényleg létre tudtak hozni egy
olyan prototípust, amelyik nagyon nagy
hatékonysággal tudtak kiszűrni a
szúnyogokat a levegőbe, és lézerrel
valóban meg tudta ezt semmisíteni. Ilyen
lézereket elhelyeztek a falu több
különböző pontjába. És lássunk csodát, a
malária járvány megszűnt. Ez a két példa
nagyon jól szimbolizálja azt, hogy mi is
a szinergia. Sokszor a szinergiát
összetévesszük. Arra gondolunk, hogy a
szinergia valójában kompromisszum. Egy
kicsit engedsz te is, egy kicsit engedek
én is, és valahol félúton találkozunk. A
kompromisszum az, amikor 1 plusz egyből
lesz másfél. A szinergia valami más,
valami meghökkentő, valami végtelen
tárháza a lehetőségeknek, amikor
találkozik egymással.
Két nyitott fél. Amit viszont gyakran
tapasztalok, az az, hogy a szinergiát
csak akkor lehet megérteni, hogyha már
részed volt benne. Mert az, aki nem
nagyon tapasztalt szinergiát a
környezetében, azt egy szép mesének
gondolja. úgy gondolja, hogy ezt valaki
egy marketing céllal elpróbálja adni
nekünk, hogy legyünk nyitottak, legyünk
kreatívak, legyünk alázatosak, de a
végső cél mégis az, hogy ő nyerjen, én
pedig veszítsek. És már el is érkeztünk
ahhoz, hogy miért ebben a sorrendben
javasoltak kávé ezeket a szokásokat.
Ugyanis ahhoz, hogy szinergikusan
tudjunk dolgozni, összedolgozni
másokkal, először is mi önmagunkkal
rendben kell legyünk. Egy egyéni
győzelmet kell arassunk magunkon.
Képesek kell legyünk fókuszálni, képesek
kell legyünk tervezni és képesek kell
legyünk kivitelezni. És csak ezután,
amiután az egyéni győzelmet learadtuk,
ezután jön a közösségi győzelem. És a
közösségi győzelemnek az első stációja,
hogyha visszaemlékeztek, az a
nyertesnyertes mentalitás. Az, aki
képtelen nyertesnyertes mentalitásban
gondolkozni, az képtelen lesz
szinergikusan gondolkozni. Ugyanígy a
mások megértése is. Ha képtelen vagyok
megérteni a másik félnek az
álláspontját, egyszerűen képtelen leszek
meghallani azt, amit ő mond anélkül,
hogy folyamatosan ne azon gondolkoznék,
hogy én mit akarok elérni. És csak
amikor ezt ennek a mestereivé válunk,
akkor jöhet a szinergia. A szinergia az
a pillanat, amikor két fél teljesen
nyitottan egy harmadik megoldást keres.
Azt mondja, hogy az én megoldásom, az a
megoldás. Az egy jó megoldás lehetne a
te megoldásod, a B megoldás talán az, de
keressünk közösen mind a ketten egy C
megoldást, amelyik talán talán sokkal
jobb, mint az A vagy a B. Ilyen C
megoldás volt maga a malária elleni
lézeres megoldás. ugyanilyen C megoldás
a DVD-nek a megoldása, és sok más
hasonló helyzetben merül fel a végtelen
lehetőségek tárháza, amikor egy ajtó
kinyílik, és rájövünk arra, hogy egy
teljesen új univerzum áll előttünk.
Gyakran tapasztalom azt is, hogy szükség
van egy mentorra ahhoz, hogy ezt a
szinergiát megtapasztaljuk. túl sokszor
félünk, túl sokszor vagyunk tele két
helyekkel, hogy ezek valóban
működhetnek-e, vagy pedig, hogyha
elkezdünk szinergikusan gondolkozni, a
másik fél ki fogja használni, és
valójában én veszíteni fogok. Viszont
az, aki egyszer megtapasztalta a
szinergiát, az már rájön. Az egy ilyen
ahá pillanat, amikor egy
paradigmaváltásban lesz részünk, és
rájövünk arra, hogy csak ennek van
értelme olyan kapcsolatokat ápolni, ahol
a bizalmi szál annyira magas, hogy
szinergikusan tudjunk együtt
közreműködni. Szóval mi is kell a
szinergiához? Az első dolog, amire
szükségünk van, az a belső biztonság,
hogy ne fenyegetésként éljen meg a másik
különbségét.
Ez a belső biztonság az egyéni
győzelemből árad. A következő, amire
szükségünk van, az a bizalom, hogy
merjek nyitott lenni és ne védekezzek.
Nyilván ez is az egyéni győzelemből
árad. És amikor a belső bizalomból
elkezdek beszélgetni, ennek a
következménye az lesz, hogy nyitott
tudok lenni, meg tudlak hallgatni téged,
és hajlandó vagyok nyertes-nyertes
álláspontot képviselni. És ugyanígy
szükségünk lesz alázatra is, hogy képes
legyek beismerni, hogy mindent nem
tudok, hogy szükségem van a te
véleményedre, és talán együtt jobbat
fogunk tudni alkotni, mint bármi, amit
én egyedül meg tudnék álmodni. Nézzünk
egy személyes példát. A feleségemmel
nagyon különbözőek vagyunk. A feleségem
nagyon szeret dekorálni, díszíteni,
festegetni, és végtelen türelemmel tud
valamit kifesteni, végtelen türelemmel
tud valamit egy új anyaggal bevonni. Én
nem vagyok ennyire türelmes. Igazából
nem is szeretem a dekorációt, és az
életem sokkal monotonabb lenne és sokkal
szürkébb, hogyha a feleségem nem
dekorálná ki azt a környezetet, ahol
élünk közösen. Ugyanakkor az én
erősségem az, hogy valami új dolognak
fogjak neki. Például egy új szerszámot
megvásárolni, egy új filmet kipróbálni,
egy új sorozatot megnézni. A feleségem
nem ennyire nyitott az új dolgok fele,
úgyhogy én vagyok az, aki általában
megrendel egy új szerszámot, kipróbálja.
Én vagyok az, aki behozok egy új
sorozatot. Én vagyok az, aki az életében
sok újdonságot megmereklépni. Valójában
egymás erősségeire építünk, és egymás
gyengeségeit ilyenkor kiköszöböljük. És
valójában ezt is szeretjük nézni újra és
újra, ezt a szinergikus hatást. Nem
véletlen, hogy manapság a legnézettebb
filmek között a legtöbb bevételt termelő
filmek azok a szuperhősös franchise-ok.
Valójában minden egyes szuperhősös rész
ugyanarra az alaplogikára épül. arra az
archetipikus, szinergikus belső hatásra,
ahol egyenként minden egyes személynek
megvan a saját szuperképessége is,
emiatt egyedi. Viszont valamiért
időnként felmerül egy olyan
szupergonosz, aki legyőzhetetlennek
látszik, és úgy érezzük, hogy itt most
eljött a vég. Valamiért mégis ezek a
szuperhősök elkezdenek összedolgozni,
egymás gyengeségeit kiküszöbölni, és
egymás erősségeit pedig maximálisan
felerősíteni. És az utolsó pillanatban,
az utolsó lehelletünkkel le tudjuk
győzni ezt a gonoszt, aki előtte
legyőzhetetlennek tűnt. Ezt a történetet
akarjuk látni újra és újra, mert ez az
igazi szinergikus történet, amiben nap
mint nap részt akarunk venni. elmegyünk
a munkahelyünkre vagy a családunkon
belül, mindegyikünknek vannak erősségei
és gyengeségei, és összefogva alázattal,
nyitottsággal, bátorsággal, bizalommal
neki fogunk és közösen elkezdünk egy
olyan problémán dolgozni, ami
megoldhatatlannak tűnt eleinte. És
amiután a végére érünk, a napunk végére
vagy a projekt végére, mi is meglepődünk
és hátradőlünk egy akár egy üvegsőrel a
kezünkbe, és arra gondolunk, hogy ez egy
igazi kaland volt. Ilyen a szinergia.
Azok az emberek, akik közösen egy
szinergikus kapcsolatban részt vettek,
azoknak a bizalmi szintje még jobban
megerősödik.
azok sokkal nyitottabbak lesznek egymás
fele, és inkább mernek nyitni a jövő
fele egy újabb együttműködésre. Emiatt
hihetetlenül értékes az, hogy egy
csapaton belül szinergikus hangulatot
teremtsünk. Volt már olyan élményed,
amikor egy másik emberrel együtt sokkal
jobb eredményt értél el, mint amit
egyedül el tudtál volna érni? Milyen
akadályokat vagy különbségeket veszel
észre a környezetedben, ami pont ezt a
szinergiát akadályozza meg egymás
között? kérlek, írd meg a véleményedet a
kommentben. Nagyon kíváncsi vagyok rá.
Minden egyes kommentre személyesen fogok
válaszolni, valamint, hogyha van egy
személyes példád, arra is nagyon
kíváncsi vagyok. Ha szeretnél mélyebben
is belemenni ezekbe az alapelvekbe,
akkor csatlakozz a Patreon
közösségünkhöz. Ott havonta találkozunk
hasonló személyekkel is, mint te, és
közösen beszélgetünk egy-egy ilyen
webinárium keretén belül mindenféle
alapelvről, olyan dolgokról, amik
foglalkozhatnak engem is és téged is. És
ne felejtsétek, csak az alapelvek
szerint élt életben lehet fellelni a
szinergiát. [zene]